from the air myanmar's southern city of
darwin
appears completely jammed thousands of
protesters blocking streets in the city
centre
they marched despite a warning from the
military that lives will be lost if the
protests continue
threat came in a statement read out on
state tv on sunday night
he blamed the weekend's violence on
emotional teenagers
but on the ground there's no mistaking
the demonstrator's message
they won't accept the military coup and
calls for the release of the country's
democratic leader aung san tsuchi
who's been held by the military in
isolation since the beginning of the
month
across the country tensions remain high
we were hoarding a city in protest and
the police cracked down on us using
force
there were many and they arrest many
protesters
a general strike is being widely
observed shutting banks and businesses
and bringing transport systems to a halt
and despite the short-term impact many
feel that's the most effective way
to make the military back down
today is a day for countrywide protest
we do not want to stay under the control
of a military dictatorship
so we came here to join the protest
regardless of the salaries we make
nothing will happen if my salary is cut
but if we stay under the control
of a military dictatorship we will
become nestled
even in the capital nepado a city whose
wide boulevards were designed for the
military to maintain control
civil servants took to the streets
but the protesters have no illusions
about the dangers they face
this candlelit vigil held to commemorate
those who've already died in the
protests
with the military and protesters both
standing their ground
real concern there's more violence to
come
tony chang al jazeera